madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues Monsieur
le Premier Ministre vous venez il y a
quelques instants de proclamer votre
discours de politique générale vous avez
posé les priorités de votre gouvernement
avec l'emphase qui vous caractérise là
est tout votre talent donnez
l'impression du mouvement alors que tout
reste figé d'ù ventreementra de l'action
de l'action de l'action saturer l'espace
médiatique de déplacement de mise en
scène de petites et de grandes annonces
espérant que cela nous fasse oublier
l'état de la France les services publics
qui s'effondrent les Français qui
s'appauvrissent le climat qui se
détériore votre rôle se réduit donc à
faire office d'écran de fumée mais les
actes ont des conséquences après 7
années au pouvoir cette année agir au
sein de la majorité et dans les
gouvernements successifs d'Emmanuel
Macron permettez-moi Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de vous juger non sur vos
paroles mais sur votre politique
commençons par votre bilan face au péril
climatique sous l'effet de l'activité
humaine le climat s'emballe si rien ne
change la terre se réchauffera de 3
degrés d'ici à 200 et loin d'agir les
États se complaisent dans un statut quo
qui nous mène à la catastrophe la France
ne fait évidemment pas exception le 10
mai 2023 le Conseil d'État exhortait
votre gouvernement à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour garantir la baisse de
40 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 inscrite dans la loi et
vous que faites-vous vous supprimez les
nouveaux objectifs climat l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie appelle à
renoncer dès maintenant à tout nouveau
projets pétrolier ou gaziier dans le
monde et vous vous refusez de stopper
huit nouveaux forages en Gironde la la
monde est entrée dans l'air des
catastrophes climatiques le nordpadcal
est subi les inondations la Réunion le
cyclone Bellal la France entière les
vagues de chaleur et vous vous soutenez
des projets autoroutiers anachroniques
tels la
69 la 6e extinction de masse sera
bientôt une réalité dans notre pays et
vous vous consacrez 0,14 % du budget de
l'État la biodiversité et détcoter le
code de l'environnement la ressource en
eau pourrait diminuer de 40 % d'ici à
2050 et vous vous refusez les objectifs
de réduction du prévèement de l'eau pour
l'industrie vous avez volontairement
capitulé face au réchauffement
climatique pourtant les conditions
vitales de l'existence ne se négocient
pas c'est pourquoi les écologistes sont
au côté de celles et ceux qui luttent
pour notre survie qui démantellent les
projets climaticiines et qui désarmment
les multinationales les écologistes
continueront à défendre des politiques
environnementales ambitieuses la loi de
programmation pour la rénovation
thermique le droit d'accès à la nature
ou encore la sortie des énergies
fossiles Monsieur le Premier Ministre
votre politique est finalement très
cohérente vous défendez ceux qui
s'accaparent la terre tout comme vous
encouragez ceux qui s'accapar les
richesse d'ailleurs bien souvent ce sont
les mêmes voici donc les conséquences
très concrètes de votre politique un
enfant sur C vit dans la pauvreté un
Français sur 4 ne mange pas à sa FA un
Français sur 10 A renoncer à se soigner
de Français sur 10 n'arrivent pas à
payer leur facture à temps et vu vos
annonces ils vont être nombreux à se
serrer encore davantage la ceinture
pourtant pour trop de nos concitoyens la
vie se rétrécit pas de vacances pas de
petit plaisir seulement travail et
facture et vous avez volontairement
capitulé face aux inégalités car soyons
honnête vous n'avez jamais cherché à les
combattre vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir
persuader et je vous cite la France
sououffre davantage d'inégalité de
destin que d'inégalité de revenus oui
combattre les inégalités de destin c'est
donner à chacun les moyens de
s'émanciper de s'épanouir grâce à
l'éducation la culture le sport c'est de
combattre pied à pied le séparatisme des
riches c'est de donner à l'enseignement
public les moyens financiers et humains
de mener à bien sa mission offrir à tous
les enfants de France l'opportunité
d'apprendre déguiser leur esprit
critique et de grandir tout simplement
mais qui peut croire un instant qu'on
peut combattre les inégalités de destin
en laissant croître les inégalités de
revenus les opportunités ne sont pas les
mêmes pour les 10 % des Français les
plus pauvres qui qui disposent pour tout
patrimoine de quelques milliers d'euros
sur un livré a et pour les 10 Français
les plus riches qui détiennent en
moyenne un patrimoine de 1,1 million
d'euros disposer d'un patrimoine élevé
ce n'est pas seulement une protection
financière c'est le droit à l'erreur
c'est le droit de prendre son temps le
temps d'hésiter de se construire de se
découvrir nous proposons donc l'évidence
non pas de tout taxer mais de reprendre
au profiteurs de remettre les super
profits au pot commun et d'instaurer un
ISF climatique l'argent magique n'existe
pas le ruissellement spontané non plus
il est de votre responsabilité de
garantir la juste répartition des
richesses pour gagner contre les
inégalités il faut mener une bataille
féroce contre ses plus grands
adversaires l'accaparement et le
surprofit là encore forcé de constater
que vous avez volontairement capitulé
vous parlez d'autorité de sanctions
contre les jeunes contre les chômeurs
contre les précaires globalement contre
les Français mais par contre vous
manquez de courage quand il faut s'en
prendre au cupide multinationales dont
les marges ont bandit durant la crise
car ell spéculent sur la guerre elle
spéculle sur les impacts des
catastrophes climatiques pour faire face
aux actionnaires qui font des
plus-values sur la difficulté des
Français et considèrent les énergies
fossiles mortifères comme une machine à
cash pendant que la planète étouffe
total réalise plus de 19 milliards
d'euros de bénéfice pendant que les
agriculteurs se démènent la fortune des
trois frères qui possèdent l'actalice
représente 43 milliards pendant que les
Naves fréatiques sa chèche les
actionnaires de NESTLE se sont partagés
19 milliards de dividendes le système
marche sur la tête pour preuve en un an
les prix de l'alimentation dans les
magasins on augmenté de 8 % pendant que
les prix d'achat aux agriculteurs a
baissé de 9 %. les seuls gagnants les
seuls gagnants ce sont les industries
agroalimentaires dont les marches sont
passé en un an de 28 % à 48
%. c'est pour ça que naturellement les
écologistes sont solidaires du mouvement
des agriculteurs il sont solidaires de
leur lutte pour vivre dignement depuis
30 ans les écologistes se battent contre
les accords de libre échange qui les
soumettent à une concurrence déloyale
revendique un revenu minimum souhaite
réformer la PAC et supprimer la dette
qui est offprès ses
exploitant Monsieur le Premier Ministre
votre seule réponse est de réduire les
protections environnementales ces normes
qui protègent la santé de nos paysans et
les terres qui cultivent une réponse
inadaptée qui n'affronte pas
l'agrobsiness choisir la facilité ne
résoudra rien la crise ne sera pas
enrayée et le déclin de l'agriculture
française continuera en bref depuis 7
ans vous avez activement volontairement
siamment capitulé face aux profiteurs
des crises alors mettons un mot sur
votre politique posons les mots et
parlons d'égoïsme pour un gouvernement
qui enrichit une ultra minorité au
détriment du reste de la nation posons
les mots et parlons d'impunité quand le
présid décide d'utiliser son statut
l'autorité de l'institution qu'il
représente la visibilité dont il
bénéficie pour écraser la parole des
femmes victimes d'hommes considérés
comme intoucha posons les mots et
parlons de déchiance morale après
l'adoption de la loi immigration qui
reprend les obsessions et les mensonges
de l'extrême droite alors que ces
ministres défilent dans nos rues à Lyon
à Anny ou à Roman surisire posons les
mots et parlons d'incompétence quand
vous êtes incapable depuis un mois de
nommer un ministre du du logement et
qu'au vu de vos annonces vous allez
encore fragiliser le logement social et
que vous annoncez tout au plus 30000
logements dans 20 territoires alors
qu'il en faut 500000 le 9 janvier
dernier vous vous adressiez monsieur le
Premier ministre à nous votre opposition
en ces termes nous avons en commun le
destin de notre nation sur ce point nous
nous retrouvons les décisions que nous
prenons ici et maintenant faceonneront
notre destin commun et celui de nos
enfants tout d'abord soyez assurés que
nous votre position de gauche et
écologiste défendons ensemble dans cette
assemblée une politique de progrès
social et de justice climatique ensemble
nous avons voté la hausse du SMIC la
prime alimentaire l'interdiction de
substances cancérigènes l'interdiction
des jets privés et vous vous y êtes
systématiquement opposé pour que notre
destin soit grand pour que notre destin
soit beau c'est un changement radical
dont nous avons besoin car vos
capitulations successives ont amoindri
la France la France doit reprendre son
souffle elle doit aussi reprendre sa
place dans le concert des nations la
France était une boussole au niveau
international cette parole écoutée a été
abîmée par la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron alors que la Cour internationale
de Justice alerte sur le risque de
génocide à Gaza la place de la France
est claire elle doit être du côté du
droit de la raison de la paix et de la
vie la France doit activement œuvrer
pour le retour des otages et doit exiger
fermement un cesser le feu immédiat est
permanent Victor Hugo définissait la
France de 1789 comme une grande lumière
mise au service d'une grande justice
nous écologistes nous battrons sans
relâche pour que la France redevienne la
nation qui l de manière acharnée contre
les inégalités nous nous battrons pour
que la France se dresse enfin contre
l'accaparement des terres et de l'eau
que la France reste une terre d'accueil
qui protège et qui nous rend fierère
nous continuerons à nous battre pour une
certaine idée de la France la France qui
ose la France qui n'a pas peur la France
qui sentraide malgré vous malgré vos
annonces rétrogrades nous continuerons à
faire vivre la lumière de la
France merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente